[Aplausos]
[Música]
cuando donald trump tomó posesión en
2017 como presidente de los eeuu todos
conocimos cómo sería su relación con el
resto del mundo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
fue el gran eslogan de su discurso lo
más destacado pero han pasado cuatro
años y ahora el nuevo presidente anunció
un cambio de estrategia américa está de
vuelta
joe biden un momento twitter otra vez un
presidente en twitter no tranquilos que
en esta ocasión los tiros no van en esa
dirección by the end lo usa para dar más
difusión a sus discursos y para cosas
tan interesantes como felicitar el año
nuevo a la etnia hmong o recordar cierta
festividad de los ix pero la cuestión
realmente importante es que quiere
decirnos bailén exactamente y con todo
esto de que américa ha vuelto es que
acaso con donald trump américa había
desaparecido evidentemente no pero por
extraño que parezca trampa ha sido uno
de los presidentes estadounidenses más
pacifistas de la historia al menos si
hablamos de conflictos bélicos e
intervenciones ha cumplido con lo que en
españa decimos como perro ladrador poco
mordedor es decir que las personas que
amenazan no son luego las más peligrosas
porque se limitan a gritar ya enfadarse
pero rara vez pasan a la acción
vale trump se desfogaba de vez en cuando
en twitter pero a la hora de la verdad
que pues poca cosa en irak y
especialmente en afganistán ha ido
reduciendo la presencia de tropas hasta
plantearse la retirada completa en el
2021 y respecto al estado islámico que
tal vez ha sido la mayor operación como
presidente en ejercicio puede se limitó
a continuar lo que ya estaba en marcha
así que al final la iniciativa bélica
más significativa del 45º presidente de
los eeuu ha sido esta en eeuu acaba de
atacar a las fuerzas de asad por segunda
vez en la historia pues eso hablamos de
un par de bombardeos sobre siria como
castigo a bashar al-assad por usar armas
químicas el resto han sido acciones
puntuales las llamadas operaciones
quirúrgicas como por ejemplo cuando las
fuerzas especiales se cargaron al
khalifa al bagdadí del estado islámico o
cuando un ataque con drones acabó con el
general iraní y soleimani y ya pues para
de contar porque a grandes rasgos este
ha sido el listado de acciones bélicas
emprendidas por donald trump en este
sentido ha sido bastante pacífico nadie
podrá decir donald trump empezó esta
guerra aunque la verdad tampoco parece
que el ejército norteamericano pues
tuviera energía para más y más
conflictos
[Música]
en cualquier caso amigo si profundizamos
un poco más enseguida nos damos cuenta
de que la política exterior del
presidente trump ha sido una ruptura
absoluta con la doctrina que había
dominado todas las acciones de eeuu a
nivel internacional desde la segunda
guerra mundial la doctrina de la pax
americana quedaos con este término si
con el tiempo el enemigo ha cambiado del
comunismo al fundamentalismo islámico
pero mantener la pax americana es el
denominador común que hay tras la guerra
de corea de vietnam de afganistán y de
irak de hecho es lo que ha estado detrás
de todas y cada una de las guerras de
eeuu claro hablamos de pax americana
pero también hablamos de muchas
intervenciones militares de hecho esta
doctrina ha recibido muchas pero que
muchísimas críticas se ha intentado
hasta reutilizar con bienes como éste
así que la pregunta que nos hacemos en
este vídeo es quizá la funcionado la
política exterior de trap y su eslogan
del america first será la presidencia de
byd en un rector no la doctrina
tradicional de la pax americana amigos
hoy en visual político vamos a responder
a estas preguntas pero antes antes vamos
a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
americana
y si os dijera que alemania tiene bombas
nucleares que me diréis seguro que
muchos os preguntaréis que como de
molinos eso es posible pero si alemania
no tenía ni siquiera un ejército tras la
segunda guerra mundial y si quien sucede
a merkel se vuelve loco y proclama de
repente yo que sé el cuarto reich pues
espera hace un momento amigos de visual
polític porque os he hecho una pequeña
trampa
[Música]
porque si resulta que hay bombas
nucleares en territorio alemán y si
cualquier otro país lo que digamos a
rusia se le ocurriera atacar a alemania
por eso hombre se podría dar una
respuesta equivalente a ese ataque ahora
bien las bombas nucleares que hay en
alemania no son de alemania sino que
están en algunas de las bases que eeuu
tiene en el territorio de este país
así está previsto de hecho la estrategia
defensiva de la otan recordad que la
alianza atlántica es un sistema de
defensa colectivo entre sus miembros que
surge tras la segunda guerra mundial un
instrumento más de la pax americana
[Música]
eeuu era la gran superpotencia global al
finalizar la segunda guerra mundial el
país representaba prácticamente el 50
por ciento del pib mundial el dólar
había desplazado a la libra esterlina
como la principal moneda de reserva del
sistema económico internacional ya nivel
militar nadie podía discutir su poder
aéreo y naval además durante unos años
se mantuvo hegemónico como el único país
con armas nucleares así que en el
washington de 1945 hicieron sus cuentas
y se percataron de que lo que más les
podía interesar era un mundo en paz pero
como podían conseguirlo pues lo primero
interviniendo los países enemigos para
que abandonaran sus regímenes
autoritarios y desarrollaran una
democracia y luego fundamentalmente con
el comercio el sueño de eeuu era que
todo el bloque occidental comerciar
entre sí ajeno a los países comunistas
bajo influencia soviética
[Música]
según washington de esta forma si las
principales potencias vinculaban entre
sí sus economías mediante el comercio
sería mucho menos interesante eso de
declararle la guerra al vecino y este es
precisamente otro de los pilares de la
pax americana si los bienes no cruzan
las fronteras lo harán los soldados
frédéric bastiat al final los bienes
cruzaron las fronteras y los países
capitalistas prosperaron
pero amigos para que las mercancías
pudieran cruzar las fronteras sin
problemas hacía falta seguridad por
ejemplo para que un barco petrolero
pueda salir de los puertos de arabia
saudí- y llegar a las costas
estadounidenses con total seguridad hace
falta que no sea interceptado por la
flota de otro país o que no sea asaltado
por la versión moderna de los barcos
piratas y en plena guerra fría los eeuu
estaban convencidos de que garantizar
por sí mismos todo este tránsito sería
la mejor forma de lograr la paz y la
prosperidad
qué
james
precisamente por eso eeuu es uno de los
pocos países del mundo que tiene bases
militares en otros países para
garantizar que sus propios intereses
estén a salvo como por ejemplo la
seguridad de las rutas marítimas
globales y ojo porque no hablamos de una
o dos bases por ahí perdidas hablamos de
alrededor de 800 bases militares
repartidas por todo el planeta
bases que han sido fundamentales para
evitar que sus aliados sean víctimas de
ataques y eso eso también es pax
americana pero claro de hecho esto
seguro que más de uno estará pensando
pero cómo es posible que un país permita
que estados unidos envíe soldados a su
territorio en tiempos de paz al fin y al
cabo es una intrusión clarísima su
soberanía no os parece
[Música]
pues todo esto amigos ha sido posible
gracias al multilateralismo hablamos de
todo tipo de alianzas comerciales y
militares entre diferentes países ahí es
donde se encuadra la otan que ya se ha
ampliado a los países de europa del este
el caso es que al final todas las
alianzas militares en las que participa
a washington se resumen exactamente
igual
declarado no el objetivo de estas
alianzas militares es que el mayor
ejército del mundo el de estados unidos
garantice protección en caso de que
ataque un tercer país claro que la
protección militar siempre exige lo
mismo bases militares en el territorio
por eso hay armas nucleares en
territorio alemán
por eso la quinta flota estadounidense
está en bahrein la sexta flota en italia
o la séptima flota en japón o por eso
hay casi 30.000 soldados estadounidenses
en corea del sur a pesar de los abrazos
de trancón kim jong-un
y claro dicho esto la pregunta es pero
esto de la pax americana ha funcionado
desde luego que lo hizo durante mucho
tiempo la prueba es la globalización de
hecho es posible que la pax americana de
llegar a su punto culminante hace 30
años cuando cayó el muro de berlín y se
deshizo el bloque comunista en ese
momento amigos el mundo comercial va en
armonía y los eeuu habían convertido en
la policía del mundo sin embargo esperar
un momento porque a partir del 2001 este
modelo empezó a hacer aguas
[Aplausos]
la primera señal llegó cuando un hombre
que había sido entrenado por la cia para
combatir a los soviéticos osama bin
laden atacó de eeuu con los atentados
terroristas del 11 de septiembre luego
llegaron las guerras de afganistán y de
irak dos desastres donde han muerto
muchos pero que muchos soldados
norteamericanos y al contrario de lo que
pasó en alemania y japón- estados unidos
han sido incapaz de convertir a estos
países en naciones prósperas y su
situación desde entonces lejos de
mejorar incluso ha empeorado y eso
explica que en los eeuu ya empezarán con
barack obama regular de su papel como
policía del mundo por ejemplo no
intervino en la guerra civil siria y
miró para otro lado cuando rusia invadió
crimen así que lo que hizo obama fue
profundizar en la pax americana pero no
desde el punto de vista militar sino
desde un punto de vista estrictamente
comercial lo que hizo la administración
obama fue dejar encargados varios
acuerdos comerciales con grandes grupos
de países que es el caso del ttp con la
unión europea o la asociación
transpacífica con 11 países de américa
asia y oceanía un acuerdo que iba a
crear la mayor zona de comercio libre de
todo el planeta una zona que poco a poco
terminaría imponiendo las reglas
norteamericanas del comercio en otras
palabras el legado de obama fue la ópera
máxima del multilateralismo comercial
pero amigos entonces entonces llegó
trump
[Música]
américa first american alone
america's forests claro a ver si donald
trump es el presidente de eeuu pues no
va a decir
tim bauer first la cuestión es que con
el america first lo que trama nos estaba
diciendo es que eeuu iba a acabar con el
multilateralismo que había desarrollado
desde la segunda guerra mundial y hay
que decir que el presidente trump no
engañó a nadie esto mismo ya lo avanzó
en los debates de las primarias
republicanas fijaos
y no solo criticó a la asociación
transpacífica lo mismo pasó con el ttp y
recordaba que incluso el nafta fue
renegociado después de 25 años en vigor
pero algunos estará preguntando por qué
trampa ha sido tan crítico con todos
estos acuerdos comerciales pues amigos
digamos que el punto de vista del
magnate era que eeuu pues no le conviene
hacer acuerdos multilaterales
trampa demostrados en un proteccionista
convencido entendió que de la mano del
comercio libre eeuu podría sufrir una
competencia desleal capaz de destruir
empleos y empresas además consideraba
que en todo caso lo que tendría que
hacer eeuu era cerrar los acuerdos
comerciales país por país porque así
siendo la potencia más poderosa del
mundo a nivel económico y militar podría
imponer sus reglas claro lo normal es
que la otra parte acepte sus condiciones
porque van a estar como locos por cerrar
un acuerdo comercial con eeuu por eso lo
primero que hizo tram como presidente
fue anular estos acuerdos pero amigos su
política exterior no se quedó ahí
[Música]
también adopta una posición muy dura en
la otra porque claro según lo mires para
eeuu la otan puede ser una bendición o
un agujero negro puede ser un
instrumento que te convierta en el
aliado prioritario de los países
europeos con todo lo que se implica a
nivel económico de influencia pero
también puede ser una hucha rota por eso
trump no dudó en sacar el latín europa
tiene que pagar una cuota justa por su
protección militar la unión europea
durante muchos años se ha aprovechado de
nosotros en el comercio y luego no está
a la altura de su compromiso militar con
la otan las cosas deben cambiar rápido
donald trump otro cambio de la política
exterior estadounidense lo podemos ver
en oriente próximo
allí la política del presidente ha sido
muy simple dejarlo todo en manos de
arabia saudita emiratos árabes e israel
y en caso de duda pues largarse el sueño
de obama ejecutado a las mil maravillas
bueno él soy contentar a toda costa
israel y arabia saudita sólo tenéis que
recordar los gestos que ha tenido con
este país con arabia saudita les apoyó
en su enfrentamiento con qatar a pesar
de ser éste un estrecho aliado y este
mismo país fue destino de su primer
viaje oficial donde se marcó el conocido
baile citó con la espada y no sólo eso
trama ha tenido otros dos gestos
importantísimos con los saudíes el
primero poner fin al acercamiento de
obama con irán y al pacto nuclear el
segundo cerrar un acuerdo para venderles
a lo saudíes armas por valor de 100 mil
millones de dólares y dicho esto ha
tenido que hacer trampa algo más pues si
por ejemplo cosas bastante desagradables
cosas como éstas se jactó de que
protegió el príncipe heredero de arabia
saudí después del asesinato de caso vil
le salve él según el próximo libro de
bob woodward trump estaba dispuesto a
pasar por alto el asesinato de llama al
caso y siempre que arabia saudí-
mantuviera el flujo de dinero y claro la
pregunta es pero esto ha funcionado o no
pues amigos la conclusión es que trae
aquí por lo menos ha cosechado si
algunos fracasos pero también algunos
eso sí no han sido precisamente baratos
porque además de tener que hacer la
vista gorda con el asesinato del caso
gay al venderle armas a arabia saudi se
convirtió en cómplice de la guerra de
yemen donde se están cometiendo graves
violaciones de los derechos humanos por
no hablar también luego de la traición a
los kurdos
por un lado tan de jaén oriente próximo
un crimen estable por las tensiones de
arabia saudí y emiratos árabes con qatar
y con irán además washington ha tenido
que intervenir igualmente cuando los
barcos petroleros saudíes y de los
emiratos han sido atacados en el
estrecho de ormuz pero por otro lado el
acuerdo de paz entre israel y los países
árabes ha sido un acontecimiento
histórico
a la fresa lo que es del césar por
último está el cambio de actitud de eeuu
con respecto a china lo que ocurre es
que trump en lugar de organizar una
alianza militar contra el gigante
asiático lo que intento es utilizar el
poder del dólar con la guerra comercial
de la cual ya os hemos hablado en visual
político un montón de veces y eso pues
eso ha sido un fracaso estrepitoso no ha
logrado nada ha perjudicado los
intereses norteamericanos y para colmo
washington ha perdido una baza
negociadora muy importante
y
[Música]
quizás si la guerra comercial nunca
hubiéramos visto la toma de hong kong sí
a ver veréis me explico digamos que
washington siempre juego la carta de las
sanciones y cuando finalmente utilizaron
este comodín pues los chinos dieron
cuenta de que la cosa no era para tanto
o al menos que estaban dispuestos a
soportar el golpe hasta tuvieron una
administración más dialogante y además
de la caída de hong kong está un poco ha
conseguido evitar que china haya tenido
una política expansionista muy agresiva
ahí está sin ir más lejos el caso de
taiwán que sigue siendo víctima de
continuas amenazas pero amigos de todos
el mayor fracaso del américa fuerte
trump se acaba de producir sin afirma el
gran acuerdo comercial días y el
pacífico con 14 países si ya lo veis sus
socios en este acuerdo son los 10 países
de la asociación de naciones del sudeste
asiático y ojo al dato con los otros
cuatro corea del sur japón australia y
nueva zelanda cuatro países que han sido
tradicionalmente los principales aliados
de eeuu en la región claro ahora es
cuando queda en evidencia el fracaso de
trump porque los aliados de eeuu han
seguido apostando por el
multilateralismo aunque la casa blanca
ya no mostrará interés en participar en
toda esta estrategia conclusión china
cada vez tiene más influencia a nivel
internacional y también más peso de las
instituciones internacionales como por
ejemplo en la oms y amigos cuando
washington da un paso atrás pekín da un
paso adelante para ocupar
el vacío en fin ya lo veis más allá de
los llamados acuerdos de abraham entre
israel y los países árabes los éxitos de
la américa fuerte
brillan por su ausencia eso sí no ha
declarado ninguna guerra y eso pues está
muy bien pero ahora la pregunta es qué
va a hacer entonces yo bailén como
presidente de los eeuu pues amigos ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
el retorno de américa
joe biden es el primer presidente
estadounidense los últimos 30 años con
una profunda experiencia en política
exterior paso 34 años como miembro del
comité de asuntos exteriores del senado
y a eso hay que añadirle sus ocho años
como vicepresidente de obama es un
convencido de multilateralismo y tiene
las ideas muy claras precisamente por
eso ha renunciado a hacer lo que hizo
obama que para representar a estados
unidos en el exterior colocó al frente
del departamento de estado a dos
estrellas de la política como hillary
clinton y john kerry frente a ello vayan
a elegido para el cargo a su mano
derecha desde hace 20 años
anthony blinken
[Música]
después de lo que puede parecer de
antros y soft interconexión y fire and
white store
de hablar de mis tres madres
es verde
[Música]
y le ha encomendado una misión por
encima de todas recuperar la confianza
de los aliados de especiales por donald
trump
efe
claro la pregunta es si está tiempo de
recuperar el terreno perdido por el 45º
presidente de los eeuu desde luego en el
caso del gran acuerdo comercial de asia
y el pacífico parece complicado que una
vez que ha entrado china eeuu logre
imponer sus reglas en cuanto al enfoque
que byd en adoptará con el gigante
asiático su idea es que estados unidos
líder accidente cuando se sienten
negociar con pekín by de nivel en que en
creen que con el apoyo de sus aliados
washington puede decirle a pekín hate
china ahí está el 60% del pib mundial no
es sólo el 25 que representa a los
estados unidos y estamos de acuerdo en
que no puedes hacer esto consideran que
así sería pues más fácil que si no
muestra más respeto por las reglas del
juego de la economía internacional como
los derechos de propiedad intelectual o
la competencia que supone el respaldo
estatal a compañías privadas como howe
de todas formas aunque la marcha de
trump suponga que no se agrave la guerra
comercial con china esto no significa
que los aranceles vayan a retirarse de
inmediato en eeuu ya no ven a china con
los mismos ojos que hace diez años
[Música]
el partido demócrata en llegó a creer
que las reformas económicas de china
traían con el tiempo una reforma
política es cierto que desde los tiempos
de deng xiaoping pocos países han
beneficiado tanto de la pax americana y
es que china ha aprovechado la
estabilidad política del lejano oriente
y las redes de comercio mundial que ya
utilizaban japón y los tigres asiáticos
pero las reformas políticas
efe más lejanas que nunca
[Música]
lo que sí va a cambiar de forma radical
es la posición de eeuu en las
instituciones internacionales de hecho
ya sabemos dos de sus decisiones por un
lado bailén planea frenar la salida de
eeuu de la organización mundial de la
salud prevista para julio del 2021 y
también quiere devolver a eeuu a la
lucha contra el cambio climático
volviendo a firmar el acuerdo de parís
ya sabéis que los demócratas se
presentaban a las presidenciales con un
ambicioso plan medioambiental para
descarbonizar la economía en el medio
plazo posiblemente amigos esas sean sus
primeras medidas en política exterior
ahora bien ninguna será tan urgente como
ésta puede que byd en sólo tenga 16 días
para evitar una carrera armamentística
nuclear
efectivamente amigos el 5 de febrero
expira el start 3 el tratado de
reducción de armas estratégicas apenas
16 días después de la toma de posesión
de bailén hablamos del último tratado
bilateral del control de armas nucleares
entre eeuu y rusia después de que trump
acabara con el tratado sobre fuerzas
nucleares de rango intermedio en vigor
desde 1987 así que el equipo de
exteriores de baile tendrá que ponerse
manos a la obra si quieren prorrogar
este acuerdo por el historial de bailén
entendemos que sí pero el futuro es
impredecible así que ahora la pregunta
es para ti qué esperas del presidente de
bailén en asuntos internacionales crees
que ha sido un error los años de la
américa forest volverá a la pax
americana es más
volveremos a ver bombardeos en la cnn
podéis dejar nuestra respuesta aquí
abajo en los comentarios y como siempre
no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos nuevos
todas las semanas así que ya sabéis
suscribiros a visual polític si aún no
lo habéis hecho muchas gracias por estar
ahí un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]